foreign
[Music]
animated series introduces an enigmatic
and formidable Titan which is as yet
unnamed we shall call it the uat
standing for unidentified aquatic Titan
due to the absence of an official name
or designation this Colossal Kaiju
possesses a visually striking and
fearsome appearance combining features
from various creatures the monster's
dominant form consists of a light blue
octopus-like body with multiple suction
cup covered tentacles also smaller red
tentacles and massive titanus clot
volumes its immense bulbous head
showcases two sets of glowing orange
eyes partially covered Adena with blue
fuzz gills and a formidable bird like
beak containing sharp teeth since the
timeline of the series was somewhere in
the early 90s Kong would have grown to
about 150 feet tall or 45 meters in
height the u80 seems to be almost double
the height of Kong and three times the
total length therefore we would estimate
it to be 250 to 280 feet or 76 to 85
meters in height and 4 50 to 500 feet
long or 137 to 152 meters in total body
length
so there are references to large
cephalopod Titans that exist within the
most diverse lore the uat stands out as
a menacing presence but is it a Titan
that has been documented or is it a new
one So within the most of us lore the
novelization of kotm mentions an even
larger variant of a cephalopod known as
the Kraken or later as titanus nakika
and although they do share similarities
nakika is more of a peaceful giant she
has a huge multi-colored octopus-like
creature with most of her body being
blue with the top sides of the tentacles
being ping in color while its eyes are
light blue in color yeah there are
similarities and she does have a very
powerful regenerative Factor but she
does not have clot for limbs red
tentacles and a Sinister personality
although the u80 might be somehow
related to her maybe the reason why
nakika got its name and was changed from
the Kraken was due to this other monster
snatching the title Kraken and yeah it
is more well suited for the name and the
role being a fully aquatic creature of
the uat possesses the ability to remain
submerged indefinitely its vibrant
bioluminescence provides it with a
striking appearance and eliminates the
depth of the ocean with a brilliant blue
light the Master's incredible speed
allows you to evade humans and ships and
Traverse the body with agility moreover
its immense strength enables it to
engage in combat with large Titans such
as gong inflicting severe injuries and
bringing their clashes to a near
standstill the creature effectively
employs its numerous tentacles for
grappling opponents and utilizes its
massive children's volumes for piercing
attacks it's a rated beak filled with
razor sharp teeth adds another deadly
weapon to its Arsenal through its
tentacles the uat possesses the
capability to deliver powerful electric
shocks to its victims the shocks are not
only potent but also accompanied by a
deadly venom survivors of the initial
electric shocks are subjected to the
slow weakening and eventual demise
caused by the Venom's effects
particularly when it comes to humans
the uat exhibits a destructive and
hostile nature its encounters with other
living beings are characterized by
unprovoked attacks demonstrating its
aggressive tendencies ship's Adventure
too close to Skull Island are met with
unwarranted assaults often resulting in
the loss of entire human Crews as the
monster drags them underwater using its
smaller red manipulator tentacles a
significant event that fueled its
rivalry with Kong was the Fatal injury
of a young woman and an entire Village
of Shipwrecked victims that made of
Coastal Village in Skull Island a group
of whom Kong had grown Faun of equipped
with electrifying and poisonous
tentacles the squid Master poses a
constant threat as evidenced by the
serious injuries sustained by certain
characters through its exposure the
master seems to be sadistic and cruel
with a vindictive Sinister motive
against gong
and with a size almost double that of
calm this creature evokes thoughts of
the legendary Kraken its ferocity is
evident through the Shipwreck sustained
in the show the creature's destructive
Rampage extends to the decimation of
Kong's friend's entire tribe ultimately
leading to her demise its dominance in
the surrounding ocean made escape from
Skull Island near impossible the uat
emerges as a force of Destruction and
also of Chaos in the animated Skull
Island series with its amalgamation of
traits from various creatures and
hostile nature this colossal aquatic
daikaju presents a formidable challenge
to both humans and Titans its
breathtaking abilities including aquatic
adaptation bioluminescence incredible
Spear and immense strength make it a
formidable opponent however its
acceptability to blunt force trauma
ultimately becomes its downfall the
unidentified aquatic Titan serves as a
memorable and captivating antagonist in
the Skull Island series leaving viewers
in awe of its power and the Peril it
poses to those who cross its path
the sheer strength and power of the
giant squid monster was apparent acid
effortlessly hurls a whale across the
island into Kong's domain and
effortlessly drowns Kong in the initial
stages of their battle its ability to
electrocute and poison prey adds to its
lethal Arsenal highlighting its
adaptability and prowess the Master's
size and strength creates an imposing
presence making it a force to be
reckoned with ultimately it is calms
resilience and determination that allows
him to Prevail against it despite its
colossal size the uat lacks the
necessary armor or durability to
withstand sustain blood force trauma
this vulnerability is exploited by Kong
who defeats the creature by
incapacitating its and relentlessly
pummeling it with his Fizz tearing the
creature in half Kong hurts the lifeless
form into the ocean resulting in a
colossal tidal wave
so that's all about the cephalopath
Titan of Skull Island series anyway I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
and new videos here on this channel take
care fam